here in calif california we're about to
have a recall vote
for governor
um because why i don't know because i
mean we're a funny state
we are just a very funny state i mean we
have this process where every four years
we elect a governor
and then people stand outside of a bonds
with a petition and enough people sign
it and then we try to unelect him
there are 46 people on the ballot i
think we vote in a couple of weeks and
uh like and this is one of them is
angeline
[Laughter]
they know her yes you know her i mean
folks if folks at home if you don't know
around the country who this is don't ask
don't ask
but
yeah
yeah gavin newsom got 62 percent of the
vote when he was elected but there's 46
people including like they all have
their little issues jacqueline mcgowan
this is you could vote for her
absolutely facilitate a fair cannabis
market is her issue
you can vote for jeff uh brandon ross if
nothing else i hope to at least be an
inspiration to addicts
this is real
i love this guy adam papagon i am just
really curious how government works
that's sort of like trump you know
i mean but you know the newspaper i must
say
it doesn't it just it does it doesn't
tell you all the people we got a
complete list of the people would you
like to hear some of the other people
yeah
like um
jamie jansen is running to get the
spitting out of porn
what
brenda silks wants to be governor
because she feels it's the most
efficient way to drive more traffic to
my only fans that
that can't be the right
reason hector montalvo wants strict
limits on the number of celebrities who
can have their own brand of tequila
[Applause]
tate brandon is running on a platinum of
no more bachelorette parties at gay bars
very specific uh chan jensen is a
one-issue candidate and the issue is
getting the gardener to stop blowing
grass clippings into the pool
i hate that
uh dusty turner says he's running
because he always wanted to see
sacramento but he can't afford a bus
ticket
[Applause]
uh amazon
he is a taliban member who just arrived
this past week he's got a very
anti-immigrant platform
he says that the only candidate in the
race with a proven track record of
kicking foreigners out of a country
and alexi kelly says she's running to
slide into gavin newsom's dms
you